Wien – das ist eine Fahrt mit dem Fiaker
vorbei an imposanten Bauten
aus der österreichischen Kaiserzeit.
Das ist ein Besuch im typischen
Wiener Kaffeehaus
oder eine Vorführung der berühmten
Lipizzaner in der Hofreitschule.
Und mit dem Riesenrad im Prater kann
man in der Gondel über der Stadt schweben.
Auch die Redaktion des britischen
Lifestyle-Magazins „Monocle“ und
ihr Chefredakteur Tyler Brûlé sind
begeistert
von der österreichischen Hauptstadt.
In ihrem Ranking der lebenswertesten
Städte der Welt kommt Wien auf Platz zwei.
Wien ist interessant
und hat bei uns sehr gut abgeschnitten.
Zum einen, weil die Stadt
wohlproportioniert ist:
Wenn man ein Jahrhundert zurückschaut,
dann hatte Wien damals sogar
eine höhere Bevölkerungsanzahl
als heute.
Jetzt hat die Stadt genau
die richtige Größe,
damit die Einwohner entspannt leben
und auch mal durchatmen können.
Im Jahr 1916 hatte Wien mehr als
2,2 Millionen Einwohner,
heute leben hier rund
1,8 Millionen Menschen.
Das führt wohl zu der
entspannten Atmosphäre,
für die die österreichische Hauptstadt
berühmt ist.
Es gibt mehr Gebäude aus der Gründerzeit als
in Paris, Budapest oder Berlin
die historische Altstadt zeugt immer noch
von der vergangenen Pracht
der K.-und-k.-Monarchie und gehört
zum UNESCO-Welterbe.
Wien ist aber auch eine Stadt der Kontraste:
Ihr Wahrzeichen, der gotische Stephansdom,
spiegelt sich
im 1990 fertiggestellten Hollein-Haus.
Ein anderes Beispiel für unterschiedliche
Baustile:
das Hundertwasserhaus.
Aber nicht nur die Architekturvielfalt
zählte beim Städte-Ranking.
Ein Hauptpunkt bei der Beurteilung
der Städte war dieses Jahr
das Bewusstsein für Mobilität.
Wien überzeugte mit seiner
Infrastruktur.
In der Innenstadt ist alles
zu Fuß erreichbar –
einer der Punkte, warum Wien
laut „Monocle“
die zweitlebenswerteste Stadt weltweit ist.
Es gibt noch viele andere Gründe,
die für Wien sprechen.
Ich denke da an die
kulturellen Einrichtungen.
Es gibt hervorragende Galerien
und Museen.
Manche Leute sagen, dass sich die
ganze Stadt wie ein Museum anfühlt –
und das klingt etwas abfällig.
Aber ich finde,
gerade das sollte man feiern.
Mit mehr als einhundert Museen
bietet Wien eine große Bandbreite
für Kunstinteressierte –
ob Malerei, Skulpturen, Grafiken,
Architektur oder moderne Kunst.
Im Schloss Belvedere gibt es die
weltweit größte Sammlung
von Gustav-Klimt-Gemälden.
Die Werke des österreichischen
Jugendstil-Künstlers
sind weltberühmt – wie „Der Kuss“.
Im Palais Liechtenstein sind Gegenstände
aus dem Besitz
der Fürstenfamilie Liechtenstein
ausgestellt.
Es ist eine der bedeutendsten
Privatsammlungen der Welt.
Komponisten wie Mozart, Beethoven,
Schubert oder Strauss
haben hier gewirkt:
Die Staatsoper Wien ist eine der
ersten Adressen für klassische Musik.
Und die Stadt hat noch
mehr zu bieten.
In Wien sind auch das Nachtleben
und die Gastronomie ausgezeichnet.
Denn hier geht das Leben
auch nachts weiter –
in vielen Clubs und Bars.
Und auch den Einheimischen
gefällt ihre Stadt.
Es ist eine übersichtliche Stadt. Es ist
eine Stadt mit Geschichten und Geschichte.
[Man] kann vieles sehen,
viel erleben.
Man spürt die Kreativität. Man spürt,
dass Kunst und Musik und Tanz
einfach schon ein elementarer … ja …
Teil der Stadt sind.
Wien ist eine sehr langsame Stadt,
eine Stadt, die diese notwendige
Entschleunigung wirklich lebt.
Entschleunigung wird auch in den
traditionellen Wiener Kaffeehäusern gelebt.
Sie sind eine Institution.
Und die Öffnungszeiten von
frühmorgens bis spätabends
sieben Tage die Woche sind erstaunlich.
Im Gegensatz zu den Geschäften in Wien:
Hier herrscht noch eine strikte
Ladenöffnungszeit, und am Sonntag
bleiben sie komplett geschlossen.
Das ist einer der wenigen Punkte, die
„Monocle“ an Wien kritisiert.
Das Magazin wünscht sich für die
Zukunft: Einkaufen auch am Sonntag.
Dann wäre Wien als lebenswerteste
Stadt Europas
unschlagbar.